[Music]
oh what about the [__] speaking of
conspiracy theories the plain lady did
you see the video of her Tiffany Gomez
probably better known as the crazy plain
lady which is completely warranted her
face doesn't look like her face yeah
that's what they're saying
she's a [__] clone
as you know I have been unwilling to
speak on the viral video but I do
finally feel that it's time
first and foremost Millennial pause
first and foremost
I do swimsuit modeling and you can find
me at onlyfans.com crazy lady
I want to
take full accountability for my actions
they were completely unacceptable
okay I will say the video is
[__] weird it definitely is weird
you know I won't say that means
anything's anything you know nefarious
is going on in terms of like government
intervention but it is a weird video I
hope that I can use this experience and
do a little bit of good in the world and
that is what I intend to do
I hope that you guys can accept my
apology and I can begin to move on with
my life oh she just wants off off that
no-fly list yeah maybe that's what it is
yeah I wish you would have been like
that [__] was real after all
I mean there is a lot of weird [__]
about this so I will say like what like
why is there a website tiffanygomez.com
that she posted the apology video on
right did she make this she did right
yeah well what the [__] is that yeah
that's kind of odd this [__] is
not real yeah
bro this is such a calculated thing I am
Tiffany Gomez this was her leaving the
airport this uh body cam footage was
released uh recently and is it is it
definitely her because a lot of people
were like taking right after she got off
the plane no but I'm saying like a lot
of people were taking that footage of
her on the tick tock and then like the
screenshot of her on the plane and be
like this is not the same person look at
it got it but is it clear from this that
it is yeah I mean she's wearing the same
stuff it's from that day from a police
body cam no I meant like the girl in the
apology video I think because this is
police body cam they also have the
police reports so they're able to
confirm like all of her information was
getting doxed recently that's why she
came out with an apology video oh I see
I think Tiffany Gomez before her crazy
plain lady video was that [__] she
drinks she's turning I don't give a [__]
I'm Tiffany [__] Gomez yeah she gets
a little crazy
and then they're like yo Tiff you got to
chill out she's like I don't give a [__]
I'm Tiffany Gomez
then she got wasted on camera and then
her old family's like the [__] are you
doing dude and they had an intervention
and now it's
I
am Tiffany Gomez yeah yeah right and now
it's a new
I think I feel like she just went to
like some 12-step program over the last
few weeks maybe that's what it was and
now she's got like just sanitized like
I'm sober yeah yeah maybe that's what it
was
you ready let's go
come on
man I can't you know is licking their
lips yeah they want to turn this [__]
into a like a real story yeah yeah
they're like what if it's Tiffany Gomez
but she was right yeah yeah yeah yeah
Tiffany Gomez What a Sad [__]
was not real yeah that's crazy they just
be hammered as hell in an airport dude
think about that you're drunk in an
airport
your [__] plane is gonna go down dude
and they're literally telling you we're
gonna arrest you yeah there's there's
like right here and she's like nah man
[__] plane's gonna go dude but not
even in like a
you're not even saying it in like a
joking way it's like yeah you're serious
fully yeah like some people are the
planes gonna go down some people are
[__] drunks some people are like sad
drunks
it's crazy to be like a sad drunk about
something that you think is inevitable
yeah that's about to happen yeah and
like a Doomer at the same time
don't don't let that [__] leave it's
gonna blow up it's gonna blow up you
ever had that feeling on a flight
yeah I have been convinced a couple
times I like this is it yeah
you know the pieces are
there's too many things going wrong
right now like it's this the one I
always look at the flight attendants
when I'm feeling unsure like even during
turbulence
if I see a flight attendant alert during
turbulence that's when I'm like okay
maybe this is yeah but they're like
we're [__] going down yeah
yeah you're supposed to be my rock but
it's really funny when everyone's like
feeling crazy about turbulence and you
look at the flight attendant and they're
like flight attendants here like flight
seat and they're just yeah
yeah true
it makes me feel better every time I'm
like oh they're just gossiping yeah and
I told that [__] she's so [__] ugly
hitting the roof rocked yeah yeah
mother-in-law is a nightmare
I met this guy in Phoenix and he was
really cool but like
guns and [__] and I'm like I don't
really know if that's for [__]
knocked out for five seconds
anyway that's for me anyway she's a
[__]
let's not gonna
move let's go I want to you can't say
that [__] in an airport yeah dude was
this like a psychotic break but that
could be
I know [__] doctor I don't know this
would man this would make me you would
cringe your teeth out if you knew you
did this I know
so true
but it doesn't really look like the same
person does it
her face is kinda
oh god I think I'm on the side
you see it doesn't take me a lot to be
convinced bro they they oh man they
cleaned up her Instagram
I bet you before there had to have been
pictures of her turning the [__] up yeah
you think so they're like get all that
out of here we really need to show the
[__] FAA that you're serious red
white and blue wow was that that was
edited two weeks ago
when was her first post
damn that [__] had some crazy caption
before then
what does that say
here fishy fishy
oh yeah dude something is a little bit
suspect nah man she hired some agency to
get her [__] no-fly [__] back all of
them were edited man throw this over the
TMG investigation I know this should be
this might we have to we
we might have to pass this case to them
detect the tit yeah and see what they
say about it
bro
traveling back to the 80s now I'm
curious man are you traveling anymore
nice
dude being on the no-fly list would be
so annoying
yeah bro
yeah I mean like my initial reaction to
that is like oh I don't like flying
that's kind of no this could be kind of
nice imagine you get hit with that [__]
in your New Mexico oh yeah and you're
like [__]
you're in Albuquerque yeah now to get
home you gotta drive yeah
drive everywhere imagine wanting to go
to New York
you never could yeah
damn well I think she kind of had some
ideas about that too yeah you know like
the plane's not gonna make yeah yeah
yeah true yeah
I'm on the no boat list yeah I did some
crazy [__] I'd see yeah yeah so I'm not
allowed oh there's no rules there what I
thought there's no rules there no I
really pissed off the maritime
law people you know how do you do that
man you can kill people the council
the maritime Council they found out
about what I did what'd you do on out on
see some some pretty messed up [__] yeah
yeah
out on the open ocean
so yeah
what'd you do murder okay yeah